-Oh, my --
No, you're too close.
-Hi!
-Ken, you're too close
to the camera.
-Oh, it's so good to see you.
I'm still getting
the hang of this, man.
-No, you're too close --
Ken, we've been doing Zoom
meetings for a long time.
You're a little bit close.
-Okay.
-Maybe I'm too far --
-Not a good angle?
-Maybe I'm too far away.
It's not even a good --
That's a perfect angle.
[ Laughing ]
-Okay.
-Just step back like another --
No, you're very close.
Just step back
another 3 feet, maybe.
No, that's --
Why you are doing that
with your chin?
[ Laughing ]
-Oh.
That's how God made me, Jimmy.
-Oh, that's not true.
-I didn't know you would be
attacking me so quickly.
-I'm not attacking.
Stop doing that with your chin.
[ Laughing ]
Ken, look at you.
That is what I wanted to see.
Look at you.
Come on.
You look great, buddy.
How you doing?
-Thank you.
Did you tell my chins that,
too, Jimmy?
Thank you.
How dare you.
[ Both laugh ]
-Are you -- you're working
harder than any human right now.
It's unbelievable,
all the stuff you're doing.
All great work, by the way.
Congrats.
-Thank you so much.
I'm just very --
just like everybody else,
just blessed to be healthy
and to be working.
It's a double blessing,
for real, so...
Speaking of doubles.
-No, no! I don't want --
The chin, I know.
Ken, I don't know
if you know this,
but your name came up
not too long ago on our show
when your pal, our pal,
Joel McHale was on the show.
-Um...
-Yeah, he --
-Oh, yeah.
He said -- I saw that clip.
'Cause Joel tweeted at me.
He goes, "Ken."
And that is my impression
of Joel McHale.
'Cause, like you, I do a lot
of great impressions.
"Hey, Ken -- [ Gibberish ] --
'Fallon.'
What are you watchin'?
I maybe mentioned you.
D-u-u-uh!"
-[ Laughs ]
Wait.
If I close my eyes...
-Yeah. "Hey, hey!
I'm gonna be on 'Fallon'!
I'm first guest on 'Fallon'!
It's great!
Bluuh!"
-[ Laughing ]
I was like, "Cool, man, cool.
Can't wait to see it."
-Great.
-And, apparently, he mentioned
that I was, and I quote,
"A terrible doctor,"
was sued way too many times,
and disbarred
and kicked out from medicine.
-That's true, yes.
-None of that is true.
-Oh.
-And it's -- He's a horrible --
I don't want --
I hope maybe we can cut this out
because I trust you
and the editorial team,
but he's a horrible person,
he's a stupid man.
-Okay.
-I can't believe I worked
with him for six years
on "Community"
on this very network.
He's been on
"The Masked Singer," my show,
like, more times
than anybody else.
I mean, there is
no worse person's essence
that I've ever worked with on
a TV set than Joel McHale.
I hate him.
He's a -- He's a stupid man.
-You want this --
He's a stupid man.
And I will never talk to him.
-You want this edited out?
-Yeah, you can write all that.
I will never talk to Joel McHale
until I see him next week
when we resume
our "Darkest Timeline" podcast.
'Cause he's amazing
to work with.
He's a talent.
He's amazing.
And so funny.
-Yeah.
-He's just
a horrible human being.
-We'll make this all --
We'll make this all work.
-Yeah, we'll make it all work.
We'll make it all work, so...
-Congrats, by the way,
because you don't have --
-And Joel's an evil genius,
by the way,
because I have things
to promote, and still,
because of that,
Joel makes me say his name
on a segment that
he has nothing to do with.
He has nothing to do
with any of these projects.
-I didn't even think
about that, yeah.
-He's an evil genius.
-He has nothing to do
with these amazing projects.
Really, I want to get to these,
because we have limited time
to talk to each other.
You have not one
but two huge blockbuster shows
on Fox right now, back-to-back.
"Masked Singer" is crushing.
Now it's in fourth season.
And then, you have your new
show, "I Can See Your Voice."
Back-to-back. You're knocking it
out of the park, man.
-Knocking it out of the park
on Kednesday.
Kednesday.
You can write that down
with your Sharpie --
Kednesday -- K-E-D-N-E-S --
because I like to be accurate.
Kednesday.
-So, Wednesday now on Fox
is Kednesday.
It's all you.
-It's all me.
-How did you figure this out?
How did you --
-Well, you know,
it's a whole process, James.
And I told the network, I said,
"I need a day all to myself,"
and they were like, "Okay.
Hey, on it.
You're the best."
And like that.
And then, I was like, "Okay.
What about Kemonday?"
I was like, "Mm.
Doesn't make sense.
Ketuesday?
You know?"
I was like, "No.
How about Kednesday?"
And they're just like, "Wow!
Oh, my goodness.
We'll make a poster."
-Yeah, "What've we been doing?"
And then, oh, my poster,
I went like this.
-[ Laughing ]
-Kednesday!
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, yeah, I know.
They did that. Yeah.
-Bood pi casa boko so Kednesday.
-Oh, my God.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, gosh.
-You know what I like about
these Zoom interviews, Jimmy?
I'm so grounded.
[ Both laugh ]
-Oh, my gosh.
Dude, I want
to talk about your movie.
You have a great movie out,
called "Over the Moon."
I loved this movie.
I watched it with my daughters.
We loved it.
"Over the Moon" is on Netflix.
The animation is insane,
by the way.
-Thank you so much, man.
It was really a labor of love,
and shout-out to the director,
Glen Keane, who --
He's an Oscar-winning director
for -- he's also animated
"Aladdin," "Little Mermaid,"
"Beauty and the Beast."
-Ken, you sing --
you sing in this movie.
It is so awesome.
I was like --
I wish I have --
I asked you for your cell number
many times, but I wished
I could text you and say...
-Yeah, I'm more of an iMessage
kind of gal, so...
-Yeah.
I was like, "Whoa.
This is really Ken singing."
Have I heard you sing before
in a movie?
-No, I've actually
never sang before,
sincerely,
maybe ever in my life...
-It was great.
-...much less in a movie.
I really appreciate that,
especially coming from you.
It was really --
I really appreciate
the directors and the producers
trusting me with their music
as well as their dialogue.
And, honestly, because it's an
all-Asian-American cast
and the message of the movie,
it's honestly one of my favorite
projects I've ever done.
It really is just --
I'm just so happy
people are liking it right now,
and I'm just truly humbled
by all of it.
-I loved it.
-I thought it had
a great message.
I thought
you were fantastic in it.
You were funny,
but then, also, like...
Should we set up
the movie at all
for anyone
that wants to see you?
-Nope.
I think we should just watch it.
-It's sweet.
A girl --
It starts off a little sad.
A girl loses her mom.
-It's about a girl dealing
with love, life, and loss.
Brilliantly portrayed
by Cathy Ang.
And she builds a rocket ship
to the Moon
to find the fabled
Chinese moon goddess, Chang'e,
played by Phillipa Soo,
who is Eliza on "Hamilton."
It's such an incredible,
stellar cast.
-Yeah, I mean, Phillipa Soo,
she's just -- just rocks it.
I want to show a clip.
Here's Ken Jeong as Gobi,
singing in "Over the Moon."
Take a look.
-♪ Do you ever
hug your scales? ♪
-Huh?
-♪ Shake your tail and
make a light show?♪
-You asked her that?
-♪ A dance of colors and hues ♪
-What are you doing?
-♪ Well, I do ♪
♪ Here right before your eyes ♪
♪ A bright kaleidoscope ♪
Surprise!
-Ken Jeong, everybody.
"Over the Moon"
is streaming now on Netflix.